my name is mark Lita and I produced the
videos that you see on my channel soft
white underbelly I've been a
photographer so it was 14 and I spent
most of my career doing advertising work
so I'm basically making helping wealthy
corporations become even wealthier and
that became that I realized as I got
older that was my legacy and I didn't
feel comfortable with that so I wanted
to do something that mattered more in
the world
the name soft white underbelly came from
Winston Churchill who back in World War
two was advising the United States on
how best to attack Germany and he's he
called Italy the soft underbelly of
Europe meaning that was its most of that
was the most vulnerable spot that
Germany had to come in from Italy these
videos are meant to create awareness of
things that are broken in our country if
we don't look at some of these things
they're just gonna continue to grow and
get worse and worse and I believe
listening understanding accepting and
maybe deciding to do something
differently might make a difference
eventually and and help the next
generation or two of parents raise kids
who have more hope have better role
models have both parents in their lives
that's my hope that's my aim with this
work it's not to help the addict that's
outside my door even though I've done
that I've done that many times I've
spent over the last 10 years I've I've
talked with about a thousand people and
I've financially I've probably spent
150,000 dollars helping people with
tents with with oh you need shoes you
need clothes you need food you need a
cell phone to call your parole officer
you need all these kind of things day
after day after day every time I'm down
here I'm bleeding money but that's not
what this channel is about has nothing
to do with this channel this channel is
purely about what I just said which is
helping our society helping our
government figure out what's wrong with
our country
and hopefully build a better system like
the the wealth inequality that goes on
here the the education and opportunity
inequalities create this stuff but I
mean I talked to some of these kids and
there were some of these people and said
when they were kids they had no hope of
a bright future there was no chance of
it so that's what I think needs to
change I've helped cymatics that's a
personal thing I do has nothing to do
with this channel I'm just showing you
with some things that are wrong with the
country sometimes that's just too much
to deal with it's just too much to look
at and I'll watch these videos or listen
to these talks listen these people and
and I'll do it on a more personal level
I'm more like individual like I see self
destructive or self sabotaging behavior
and myself and I'll I'll be able to
apply this story that I'm hearing maybe
not as extreme some of these stories are
really horrifying but in my childhood
there's nothing like these but the
mechanics are so the same you know the
stuff that happens to you as a kid ends
up affecting the way you believe in
yourself which ends up manifesting as
problems with
Oh alcohol or drugs or your diet or
taking care of your health or your
choice of partners or your career
choices or your belief in yourself and
the education that you decide to get and
there's so many things that we get in
our own worst enemies sometimes and I
think that's an interesting story as
well and if you watch these videos
you'll be like wow that that's what was
going on with them that's why they're
doing what they're doing and then you
can kind of apply it to your own life at
least I can other times I just find
listening to all these talks like a
crash course in empathy I used to look
at homeless people and go man why don't
they just get a job quit the drug get a
job problem solved
and now after hearing all these stories
I realized what these people have gone
through in their childhoods how they're
broken how they'd never had a chance
they never had hope and that it really
has changed it's built my compassion and
empathy for these people like like
nothing else and then other times I
can't handle any of the above and I just
watch these videos as like interesting
character studies I get to listen to
people that I'd never would never ever
meet in my life and they're interesting
and fascinating and I leave it at that
that's all I can bite off for the day so
if you have the strength and courage to
watch these videos that's great and if
you don't I understand isn't there not
for everybody but if we're gonna change
our country we're gonna need to
understand why it's broken what's wrong
with it and here's a really good window
into what's really going on I hope I
hope you enjoy my work and thank you for
watching oh and by the way there's
there's a there's a handful or more
videos that have been deleted from my
channel for various reasons and starting
tomorrow I'll start uploading those
videos again there's a slightly change
to protect the subject or for some
reason just to match to meet YouTube's
community guidelines or whatever it
takes so that they
get deleted and you'll start seeing
those tomorrow there's they're some of
the best videos I've done and I just
thought it was a shame that they don't
exist on my channel so you'll you'll
start seeing those tomorrow and thank
you for watching
you